joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line right here on the rich eisen
show is one of the sharks from shark
tank where new episodes air fridays at 8
pm eastern on abc
but his second annual black
entrepreneurs day presented by chase for
business will air today exclusively on
facebook and the man who hosts the event
that's taking place live from the apollo
theater in harlem damon john back here
on the rich eisen show how you doing
damon
i'm well i'm well i love it when i get
to pop in on the show uh appreciate it
hope you're doing well yeah i'm hanging
in there i'm hanging in there uh first
things first about shark tank um
you know you did get the nomination
right for for shark tank correct
yeah and yeah okay we got two
nominations okay very good and and so
obviously folks might not know this but
i did uh host the uh for your
consideration video with you and the
rest of the sharks
so um my way of asking of how much am i
a factor in all of your success damon
john
starting this interview well we lost we
lost this year but um
it was clearly barbara's fault as always
okay so all right yeah all right so but
hey at least you got nominated and um
that's right all right so i was a factor
in that is basically where i'm starting
yeah yes absolutely okay
i'm just looking for that you know my
guys around here understand how uh needy
i am for that sort of uh affection um
hey man i understand it i appreciate it
um so
uh second annual black entrepreneurs day
walk anybody through who might have
missed the first uh black entrepreneur's
day about the genesis of it and why
you created it damon john yeah uh and
thank you but so you know obviously when
we were looking at the whole world kind
of unfolding with brianna taylor and
george floyd and and people of all
colors were getting together in the
streets and many of them and almost most
of them were doing peaceful protests but
they were
you know i i was seeing other people you
know as we all did looting and burning
down businesses when i said you know
these
they need inspiration they need
information on how to build a business
instead of burning a business because
we're all frustrated you know and uh but
you know their their journey needs to be
about education so i uh called a bunch
of celebrity friends called up a bunch
of sponsors and said i want to do
something to give away money grants to
black businesses who are
are less likely to get money and and i
want to interview a bunch of celebrities
and talk about their failures and how
they pivoted and how they're here today
so last year i did that and this year
i'm back doing it but as we open up i'm
able to book the entire apollo theater
and we are doing it tonight live from
the apollo theater and uh shaquille
o'neal
kevin hart tyra banks run from run dmc
michael strahan all will be interviewed
and told about their story and we're
giving away a quarter million dollars
um
10 grand some 25 000 to uh to black
businesses that are in need
that is uh quite a a group that you have
gotten together for
for for tonight and for this event at
the apollo theater and for a remarkable
cause and and in terms of
that the fact that we're calling it a
cause and the fact that or at least i
just did and the fact that that that
that we are in this day and age
trying to call attention to diversity in
ownership
of businesses and entrepreneurship and
you know in the sports world right now
there's a large conversation based on
um some emails that came out from the
now former coach of the las vegas
raiders and john gruden and a member of
the washington football team management
team at the time 10 years ago and a
whole bunch
since then about the lack of diversity
in positions of power certainly in the
sports world what is the challenge damon
john what have you found in your
experiences
and what are you trying to throw a
spotlight on that is the challenge for
diversity in
positions of power
i find that most people don't want to
address it i find that you have the ones
as i said who collectively of all colors
got together and have always fighted
anything whether it's apartheid civil
wars or anything else like that and as a
small group then you have the people who
are on the bad side who have an
intention and they feel that holding
back somebody is in some way or another
are going to benefit them it's the 80 in
the middle that are saying i'm not sure
this is real maybe i should do something
maybe i shouldn't and i find that that
is those are the ones that need the
education to understand why there has to
be a conscious effort to diversify in
various different ways of course gender
color creed and and color um but when
you do that you also get innovation if
you have the old boys or the old girls
come all thinking the same way you don't
get anybody to hack the system that's
exactly how fubu got here i didn't put
three sleeves on his shirt nobody was
addressing the fact that there was a
young market of primarily people of
color that love hip-hop music but also
once i created google there were people
of all colors who said we love this
culture and that's how it got to be so
big by getting with other people who
said you're right and i can help you
what you're doing and we're gonna both
make money and create change i love that
you said you didn't put three sleeves on
a shirt
i i love that and but but what so what
is it fear is that what it is for for
just to try and find diversity or
or it's just people i think that a lot
of people really they're too close to it
they don't or they're too close in their
bubble they don't believe it's happening
and listen i got to tell you the way
black ops news they came out was when i
reached out to a lot of organizations or
they reached out to me after the george
boy thing they said
i thought i was doing enough but i am
not clearly not doing enough but i don't
want to put lipstick on a pig i don't
want it to not be genuine where do i
start and that's where the conversation
starts to happen when you can say
where do i start is there a way that i
can help uh change this narrative on
what's going on in corporate america or
you know in the streets or in the world
you want to you want to you want to stop
making it twice as hard for an
african-american man and woman to move
into position or you know thinking the
two felonies are the same or people can
die over air fresheners or broken tail
lights or counterfeit bills uh and you
want to change that narrative and but
you have to make a conscious effort and
you have to educate yourself on why the
system systemic thing have been in place
and how you can change them what what's
the one that did you experience as you
were trying to build fubu when you were
sent to your current position where you
you encoura you you
um encountered a roadblock on this front
damon
you got one story i've been on that i've
been i've been pulled over plenty of
time but i've had guns put to my head by
cops and they've called me obviously the
n-word and you know i was only guilty of
having a bunch of t-shirts in my trunk
and trying to touch the stars that was
it period
um it is common in the black community
to to have that happen
um uh and many of my earlier partners
had been incarcerated for things they
didn't do and they would have to have
the innocence program uh you know fight
their case and get out ten years later
realize yeah and say you know i'm we're
sorry we realized you didn't do it now
here you go so it is it is very close to
me um
i i've seen it all all too often damon
john here on the rich eisen show the
second annual black entrepreneurs day
presented by chase for business will air
today exclusively on facebook and then
just for you um
damon i mean
if i had told you when you were just
starting fubu and you told my story on
my podcast just getting started a few
months ago that you'd be renting out the
apollo theater
with a whole bunch of highly successful
individuals who are very excited to
share your story
uh or their stories with you
what would you have said
absolutely
no you know 30 years ago i stood in
front of that same apollo theater
selling shirts and then then i made a
little bit of money you know in the in
the mid 90s to be able to buy a ticket
to the apollo theater now i'm able to
take the stage and book the theater for
you know for the whole day and give away
money to
hopefully the next person who's going to
change the planet you know i have a lot
of hope in entrepreneurs um and and i
stand side by side with amazing people
like chase for business and the general
insurance and people like you who are
helping to promote this initiative and
so many people of all colors who want to
stand side by side and say we want to
help and we want to give other people
opportunities so i always you know
listen rich there's always going to be
some nasty ugly things happening in the
world
i'd rather look at the more beautiful
things of the world and say that they
can set examples of how we can all get
together and and help each other yeah
like somebody who's got a dream he's got
an idea a really good idea and a lot of
determination and suddenly you go from
selling shirts outside the apollo to
actually renting out the apollo that's
what you do absolutely that's the dream
that's good that's the dream and so how
many people come up to you with an idea
a crazy idea all the time damon they
stopped you like oh you mean my mother
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how do you say no how does how do you
turn her a shark with your own mother
you don't do that i can't say no she's
the one who came up with some of the
ideas of fubu too so you know i get
approached i get approached dozens of
times right in the street and i get
hundreds hundreds of even thousands
online at the end of the day um it's
somebody just trying to fulfill their
dream and and um and feed their families
and and bring value to the world so it's
an absolute honor the day that uh the
day that i get tired of getting uh
getting those pitches uh is the day that
i should i should
sit down from shark tank i realize those
cameras are there
and i was all i was that part that
person pitching ideas and it's an
absolute honor okay well i'm in the
bathroom a public bathroom except for
when i'm in the public yeah i mean
eating right like don't bother you when
you're having dinner or you know uh
doing whatever business outside of the
world of business that you're doing um
but
that said damon john uh i have my
rich eisen show
social media grand maester to my right
t.j jefferson um there you go who you
have you have a pitch you want to give
to damon john right t.j jefferson that's
what you said to me correct well damon
it's not a it's not a shark tape pitch
necessarily and i want to say what up
first and foremost the last time i think
i saw damon john he was over at wilma
valderrama's house and we were watching
the ufc fight ladies and gentlemen uh
that's right yeah oh yes very good so
damn i'm looking at the phone
i'm looking at your fubu page and i saw
the other day that you have an ad to
become a fubu ambassador and i was just
thinking right like
an ambassador you know someone who's
going to show love for the product and
someone who knows and loves the product
and i thought to myself who better than
someone who in his you know 20s spent
all his money that he made at foot
locker in pittsburgh putting on
layaway a few fubu sweatshirts and fubu
hats and who now
you know sits in front of probably a
couple million people daily millions
millions people daily as part of a you
know national sports talk show damon i
thought who could be a better ambassador
than someone like i don't know me who
loved the product who wore fubu and you
could sit here every day and you know
you know
toot your horn find that uh yeah yeah i
find that fascinating just a thought dan
and john just the thought yeah
so um i i know i like that pitch um
how much are you willing to pay to
be an ambassador see i didn't know that
that's how that worked
i
i thought like as an ambassador i would
i would you get stuff and then you know
rock it and then you're right you're
right but i just figured listen if i
don't ask i won't get it's true you're
right here's the deal damon you know the
shark is swimming i'd pay let's see i've
spent probably a couple grand in fubu in
my life so i'd probably uh go you know
maybe a thousand to win that you know
but i don't want to like look at like
i'm trying to bribe you yeah
all right well let's get it done let's
get it done one way another okay because
i know jared nixon would love
and value the product in the brand so
absolutely so not only tj if you don't
mind me just like adding on top not only
have you purchased fubu oh because
you're a fan of food
but you have put on the referee shirt
and sold fubu products at the foot
locker back in altoona pennsylvania
pittsburgh pittsburgh pennsylvania back
in the day you've done both correct we
had we've been carrying food your
ambassador you were already an
ambassador hey 95 96 97 98 you still
want it though you know you still want
it though right sure you know all that
grew out of all that stuff you know so
damon what is he got to do to fill out
the paperwork or can we cut through the
red tape what can we do he already here
you know he already knows my guys oh he
got well he got okay
that's it
all right very good that's uh i think
that was successful tj thank you dave
johnson appreciate it all right damon
john i appreciate it thanks for the time
greatly appreciate it um and once again
the second annual black entrepreneurs
day presented by chase for business
airing exclusively today on facebook
from
the brilliant beautiful jewel in harlem
known as the apollo theater thanks for
the time appreciate it damon thank you
you got it that's damon john also check
out shark tank fridays 8 p.m eastern on
abc
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here